no no loop no loop no loop sorry i'm like back and i was like oh i don't have any messages and then i got so many work messages all at once by like three different people that i had to like go over so i was just like oh my god and it's like um there's some last minute adjustments to the the halloween thing i'm doing tonight so like um like the person is can only be awake for the next hour to fix it because I was giving notes because I sent the thing that I'm planning on like a little surprise I'm doing for Halloween so I was sent the thing when I was asleep um so when I woke up I was like oh shit okay um I had to go I was like testing everything out and I was like oh here are my notes to see we could do some last minute change like last minute edits to it and last minute um fixes to the thing whatever it is that I'm doing for Halloween So I was like,
you know, going through everything and be like, can we do this?
Can we change that?
Like, I know I'm so sorry.
I know it's so, it's the last minute.
But I, like, yeah, I received the thing, like when I was asleep.
So I couldn't be awake to look over everything.
But yeah, I'm nervous.
I'm nervous about the Halloween thing, as always.
Like whenever I do something special, like, oh, you're hearing static.
Oh, that's just my bathroom.
It's because my bathroom thing is...
on.
It's not static.
It's, I don't know what it's called in English.
It's called Taofung in Cantonese.
I don't know what it's called in English.
It's like the, you know, when you're taking a shower, is it, is it called the extraction fan?
Is that what it's called?
But that was on.
That's what you were hearing.
Yeah, I never knew what the English word for it is called because that my you know my parents would call it uh taofong in cantonese and so that's the only thing i know it as i never learned the the english word for it they'll just be like oh turn off the the exhaust fan in chinese and i'll just be like okay we're gonna turn it on uh but yes i am back for more rivals um for your consideration for the nom that just be because i realized i i wanted to stream this week just so I could like you know pad my stats up for the nomination and shit but I was so I was I've been like super tired um lately because I literally I told you guys like yesterday um that's why we had like such a short stream yesterday because I was so fucking exhausted because of what I had to do the day before yesterday um so like all the the tiredness is building up so I literally passed out at 10 p.m.
and I woke up at 4 in the morning and I was like fuck I was just like fuck I was supposed to do my DJ now stream so I guess we're here I guess we're alive at this time what you're gonna do morning stream it's still um we're still terrorizing people but now we're gonna terrorize them in the morning as well because who because you're because like the people Are either people who like have been playing since three in the morning or?
Or they want to like they want us or they just don't have a job, I guess, or they're not going to.
Or they hate themselves and they're playing in the morning.
True.
Most of them.
So or they're European or they're European.
You're right.
Or they're children.
I mean, bullying kids.
What else is new?
Ring or they're sneaking in ring before work.
Why the fuck would you do that to yourself?
Why the fuck?
Skull, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Or they worked the night shift and they just got off of work and now they have to deal with me terrorizing their lobbies.
That's fucking right.
All right, let me make sure the sound and everything is good to go.
up anything yet so um i literally just put put myself on the screen and i was like that's good enough i'll do that lot i'll do the rest live all right i always save my sound settings uh okay now it's time to boot up the rivals the marble rivals yeah exactly that they can't get any worse when they started off with rivals but yes please for your consideration feel free to nominate me um for best marvel rival streamer i'm doing this for this i technically i do have a pack schedule this week but like apparently nominations ends next week and like my twitch channel looks really sad so i when the i don't want the judges to look at my twitch channel and be like wait they wanted us to nominate her like so um So I have to make sure my Twitch chat looks not as sad when they look at it.
Yeah, because I'm pretty sure the other nominations, they like stream this game every day.
So they'll be like, did we just got like bought it or some shit?
So I don't want to think that I bought it the nominations.
Like, I don't want them to think that.
Wait, she shoots two times a year.
Yeah.
You know, so, you know, for your consideration, I gotta make myself look like, uh, look like I'm alive on this, on this channel.
Uh, let me fix my display real quick.
All right.
All right, it's so weird.
My, my rivals keep spooting up on my second monitor.
I don't know why it does that.
I have not, I couldn't fix.
I can't.
I try to fix it, and I spent like an hour.
it and I was like that's enough that's how much it deserves like oh shit let me okay I gotta send an update on something um let's see I got sent a um all right sorry give me I need to do some notes real quick like I said like they're only a live for another hour so they're only they're only a for another hour and then like after that what we get is what we get for halloween so i gotta fix this um i stream more than there's no way i stream more than necros and uh bogey because like rivals is like their main shit i'm just the appetizer to the main meal Okay.
Alright, this part, okay.
Okay, I'm trying to make sure I don't accidentally say anything because then it'll reveal what this is.
Sorry, I gotta make sure I don't reveal what this is.
So I'm, like, saying it in my head and hoping I don't, like, say it out loud.
That's basically it.
Okay, there we go.
But yeah, I don't know why my, oh, by the way, remember the guy that said the gamer word?
There you go.
He got muted.
That's fast, actually.
The guy got muted for saying the gamer word.
Anyway, all right, let's go.
Let's go queue up, I guess.
Let's go terrorize the morning people.
They thought, I mean, to be fair, if they're playing this game this early in the morning, like, they know what they're getting.
They're not here to climb.
They're not here.
Climbing is not what they're aiming for right now.
It's just pain and suffering.
And I'm here to give it to them.
I am their EOMM agent clocking in.
Well, to be fair, I'm not grinding for anything.
I'm just here to make sure someone's not having a good time.
Not on purpose, of course.
Not on purpose.
It's just my mirror exists.
They'll be like, oh no, Jokey Burr's back online.
Is it lagging?
No, that's fine.
Oh yeah, I found a new...
I found a new RP meta.
Where are the women?
Oh, there it is.
I need to find that one.
Where are the women?
Okay, wait, why are we fighting?
This is RP.
Hello, Mantis.
Do you have dance emo?
Oh,
she does.
My worker!
My staff!
Don't worry, guys.
I have a new meta.
A new RP meta.
I gotta wait.
I need to wait for her to come back.
You know the one.
All right.
Don't worry.
New RP meta.
I was like, this guy is a genius.
Whoever, I'm going here to start a business real quick.
All right, there she is.
There she is.
All right.
Come on.
Would you, do you want to, do you want to have a job?
Can you do, do you have it?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, shit.
It's the wrong skin, but it works
That's right A new business has opened up, everybody No, Katie, please Anyway, no, my business I just, it's my startup I took a loan for this Alright, wait, which one was?
I think it's regular Yeah, it's a regular rocket Let me double check No, I don't have to wait 30 seconds.
Sorry, I did take another loan at the bank.
Oh, yeah, no, no, I just, I did take another loan from the bank to get this to work.
All right, don't worry, girl.
I'm going to make you a star.
Oh, my God.
Please don't kill my only worker, my only staff, Mb.
All right, here we go.
Don't worry, girl.
I'll make you a star.
Does she have it?
There you go.
Come on, girl.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Pay customers only!
No!
No animals allowed in my facility.
You were so...
You can't do that.
Anyway, so I learned.
that the new role play meta now is to start a strip club that's the that's it that i'm a business owner now you're literally only i can be the one animal allowed in the strip club yeah this is the strip club meta now we're we're in the new age of role playing dinner and exactly dinner and a show wait where is she These guys don't deserve my strip club.
I'm here pioneering.
I am here pioneering the new roleplay meta.
Go dance for me, girl.
There we go.
Yeah!
What is this?
Dinner at Stats, right?
Yeah!
Guys, I think this is it.
I think I'm gonna be be a millionaire.
I need absolute critique.
I think guys, I think I'm gonna make it.
I'm gonna make it here.
Once dinner.
No!
I only worked it!
Oh my god, I swear to god.
You guys better be dancing.
I need, I need more dancers for my business.
Come on, Spider-Man.
I know you have a dance emo.
Come on, Don't dance on that pole, girl.
Sorry.
I'm the...
Everyone else is fine.
Come on, dance.
Get out of...
No animals allowed!
Get out of here.
No animals allowed in the strip club.
Only one per club.
Alright.
Come on, dance.
No!
What the fuck out of here?
How can I be a successful business owner if everyone He's destroying my one only poll that I can have.
That the health inspector allows me.
Only I am an entrepreneur.
I will make you a star, girl.
Bro, what the fuck's this gonna kill?
I'm in Celestia.
What the fuck?
Guys, what happened to my degenerates?
What happened?
I know it's a Thursday.
But where are you guys?
Wait, is it Friday?
Wait.
No, it's a Friday.
Guys, it's a fucking Friday.
Where the fuck are you guys?
Come on.
What the fuck?
There you go.
All right, girl.
It's time.
Stop!
We are undefeatable!
We on Arc...
I have not played Arcade.
I don't know.
It's just all extraction shooters.
It's like, what flavor of extraction do you want?
There we go.
Bro!
get out of here get your oh fuck oh no not the shark he's just mad because i wouldn't let him in the strip club i am a ceo here you know who you're talking to
it's just different flavors of extraction oh you know what game i would you want to try the new
It looks fun.
That looks really fun.
Oh my god, there you go.
Now I have two.
Okay, give me a sec.
Give me five seconds.
I don't worry.
I took a seventh loan at the bank.
Pulls are apparently buried.
No!
Don't mess with the amazing...
I just got it.
What hero do you think you want to be?
girls too all right i got enough practice to play i got enough practice for it all right let's see what's this now who am i gonna banish from this match
okay this is as good as we can get okay yeah yeah i think i think that looks a lot better than it to before.
Alright, that's as good as we can get.
Oh, they didn't ban anything.
At least it's not us.
Alright.
I finally got a second dancer in the cute pops.
I know, right?
Like, there's just no place for an honest businessman anymore.
It's just no place for me.
And then, town.
Thank you for the uh, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
They banned zero?
Like, how do you ban nothing?
A smoky.
Thank you.
A hundred bitties.
Minji, thank you for gifting a sub to Wizard.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm like, what the fuck?
Also, why the fuck is this guy still playing at this time?
Not banning nothing.
They're that confident.
I fear the man who bans nothing.
He's like, I can play it.
They're like actual flex guides.
They're like, I fear nothing.
That's crazy.
Not banning Daredevil, too.
That's looking insane.
Yeah, I have known many over the years who would wish to control me.
stream today just because like i said um also the reason why we don't have a waiting room for a halloween stream is because i don't have the thumbnail yet so i'm just waiting on that i don't even know if i'll take a nap later who knows i do want to do another arrival stream because apparently nomination ends uh nomination ends like november 3rd or some so um i feel like i should just get as many streams possible oh look there's a spider man you know that I'm not not right now a fucking invisible woman oh I'm so wow that could have been me guys that could you're right I should you're right them not banning anything you're right no fear all right look guys we can move forward right we can press the W key right guys are you guys really afraid of one little spotty man come on guys move up w key guys come on it's not that come on guys let's just walk forward we've been stuck in this one corner because of one spotty man oh my god i swear to god there we go there you go the evil is defeated
let's just oh okay goodbye daredevil i there was no way i can heal harder than that i'm i have not all right there you go let's go Let's go.
Come on.
There we go.
Look at that.
We did it.
What the fuck?
Oh, that's unlucky.
I did not realize that he also wanted to be.
Put his res here.
Look, both of us had the same idea.
Look, we both, unfortunately, had the same idea of what we wanted to do as Rocket.
He just was there first because it was his home.
Who requires healing?
Well, you're like all the way there, so I don't know.
Oh, shit, he's alive.
That's surprising.
I still died.
I just threw it off.
Guys, I don't think it's winnable.
I don't think it's winnable.
I have a feeling that my team, you know what?
No wonder they didn't ban anything.
No fucking wonder.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm just a fucking a fucking trash panda.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
I'm not even allowed in restaurants.
Here we go.
There we go.
Can we move up?
Oh, shit.
Why did she double support Altan?
What the fuck?
I mean, all right.
There you go.
I don't know why we double support Altan's that.
Like, oh, wow, that's on you.
You know, you double support Altan.
Thank you.
All right.
Now you have...
No one.
Hello guys.
I'll stay here.
Wait, I can stay here.
Wait.
Wait, this is, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh shit!
Okay, I did not think he was gonna look at me.
Like out of everybody, I guess he decided to look up.
Who the fuck looks up?
That was so fucking smart of me.
Like how good of a life you have that you actually are aware of your surroundings.
Yeah, just like fucking casual.
Only casuals look up.
Who the fuck does that fucking freak?
Looking up in this economy?
Exactly.
No, I don't think we're winning this.
I- I have- there's- I'm not confident in our- team anymore yeah there's nothing i could do there like all i could do is just go in my team and hope y'all kills everyone too and hope everyone dies for the y'all so i'm not alone i can't even put my reds the spider-man's gonna look for it the right queen's reign begins oh yeah i was gonna say Oh,
yeah, of course he's got a bent.
Oh, he fucking fucked up.
Yeah, he's bent.
Oh, shit.
He's bent.
All right, guys, let's go.
Let's go.
Oh, they have store.
Oh, they're doing a shark native.
Thing is, I can't really put it here.
The spy man's gonna show up on that side.
Yep.
Oh, I hope we do something about that shark.
Well, that's fine.
We're not.
We don't need to do anything.
I mean the fact that oh hello goodbye goodbye I'm a little worried about that there's a spider-man behind us guys against their cough all right so if I go up here the spider-man's gonna fucking come up to me but like I guess that's the risk I'll take oh sharks oh no shark Do we have up?
Oh, nice.
Oh.
Goodbye, Punisher.
Oh, unless.
Unless.
Oh, is he going to kill anybody?
Well, let's find out.
He has one kill.
Look at him go.
Oh, that poor Loki.
I can't believe it.
The Spider-Man didn't see me.
He doesn't look up anymore.
Look at that.
He thought he was becoming a gamer.
So you stopped looking up.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, yeah, Mag is good against anything.
Mag is like, literally, like, the best tank you can play.
Overall.
Like, where the fuck do I put this that's not gonna get destroyed?
Like, everywhere I go, the Spider-Man's just gonna show up.
You know what?
Fuck this.
Oh, wait.
I thought I had ult.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
We timed it perfectly
See look at that perfectly timed as expected No, no, no, no, no, no.
See look me like see because I I didn't have all I had it just in time for spider man It's not awkward guys because it worked out in the end It can't be awkward if it actually worked out.
You might...
Oh, they got my...
Why the fuck?
Okay, he got my...
Alright, guys, this is awkward.
Now it's awkward because we don't have res.
Oh, and there's that.
Yeah, mag is just good overall.
It's just...
That's just how it goes.
Oh my god, did our mag...
No, that was the enemy mag.
I mean, it'd be good if we have...
If we have portal.
Portal, guys.
Is anyone on a portal?
Wait, we alted?
We fucking Luna alted?
We are not portaling.
Okay.
That's cool.
I thought one of us would go to portal, but that's alright.
The current score is 2.
That's okay.
Alright.
See, we have one last.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
all right nice okay we're good we're good to go yeah I was surprised I thought someone would pour it out that's okay we don't need it right we don't need it we're so confident about it oh dad's awake he's awake I let him he won the mental battle so now he's allowed on the bed again I'm a good guy who occasionally takes stuff that doesn't belong to him.
It's like, you know, if he doesn't get in my bed, he gets really angry.
And like I, oh my god, okay, give me a sec.
Mine's near entrance.
This round shall be no different.
I suppose you've made quite a name for yourself.
So the issue is that ever since I got the noise complaint, I'm a little more worried of whenever he starts barking.
Whenever, yeah, so like, I just get like a little nervous when he starts barking because I don't want to get kicked out.
If I'm going to kick out, it's on my terms, not on his.
Really?
Oh my god, there's nothing I can do.
There's no...
He has to play Animal Crossing if he wants to live.
Like, he has to play, like, Jeff or some shit.
Like, or he's not gonna be alive with this guy.
You'll be able to patty kick this way.
I don't even think a patty kick is gonna do anything.
I'm doing my best to, like, keep them up.
as in like right click I'm literally I'm just right-clicking I have I have not stopped right-clicking since we started like I I don't know man I've just been right-clicking bro they're gonna heal it yeah but we're we're out of we're out of fucking resources too okay you and me you and me oh no that's That's fine.
That's fine.
Look at that.
My one-old has saved this team.
Jeff's silent ulted.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, that is not fine.
I mean, can we, it's, oh, bro.
Oh, goodbye, Envis.
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh, you had to walk into the Spider-Man.
I love you.
Oh, why can't you walk to me?
I had a res, bro.
I had a res.
Jeff is opening.
I feel like that's a bit too much.
Bro, there's nothing I could do.
That's okay.
We have res.
It's getting Jeff's coming over.
Another healer is coming over.
We're just taking shifts right now.
His shift is arriving don't worry clocked in okay here you go just go under one and somebody can't kill you ever all right here we go top but they give you the twitch prep don't worry i'm clocking in now guys i'm clocking in for my shift to oh my god oh my god please no no okay i'm okay i'm okay now i'm okay i'm okay now i'm okay i was trying to use my res as like as like Like my,
uh...
You might have to kite it.
Oh.
Did we, were we kiting it?
Are we kiting?
Oh, we're not kiting it.
I think we win this.
I think we win this one.
Guys, we're down three.
I don't know.
Do we have a res?
Do we have a portal?
Use a portal right now!
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
He's using it.
We're TPing?
Just fight.
Good.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna have to run it down.
I don't know what he did please okay it's fine there we go magic one we got this magic one we used everything but we got this magic's absolutely one okay we have no support all that's fine okay I gotta put this thing away because I'm scared I'll put it here there's no way they'll know I don't know if they used everything too like that's what I'm wait maybe if I hey guys um they're right behind us hey guys I think they're right by oh oh that's not good that's not good yes that's very unfortunate that they were you guys we didn't turn around but we literally called portal
like it's crazy that no one turned around we did okay let's stop it yeah they're like they're portaling you mean we should push up the spawn all right he's right behind me isn't he i mean they have like a one singular Jeff so maybe where the fuck do I at all I don't know where the fuck puts this res though to be fair like dude there's no way he'd show up here right whoa yes he did sorry Jeff you fucked that red oh sorry bro There's nothing you...
Oh, wait, he lived!
You know, I legitimately thought he was...
I legitimately thought it was like over for that guy.
Really?
We're not gonna...
I feel like Mag would be...
Yeah, he was gonna save.
We really need...
Wait, what are we doing?
What are we doing, guys?
Hello, everyone.
Um...
Guys?
Guys...
I don't like that word.
We let them free push that much, because you wise to swap i don't like that oh no oh no it's okay i'm still here somehow guys why did we all decide to swap our entire comp while they were pushing what the fuck why couldn't you swap like what before that happened that's okay that's okay it's fine at least we know it's not me these are the morning hours there's no reasoning there's no reasoning or rationale in morning hours like they don't use we don't use our brain it's all vibes it's all vibes guys guys can we push up please we're giving them the we're giving them three two three pushes right now
okay good our silo got zero oh god two kills thank god i was gonna say if you get zero kills on the silo call with her recent buff like i don't know maybe silo's not your thing
all right i'll just put the red res here i'm afraid of the spider-man Okay, we do have, they still have one support, guys.
That means if we do, if we have more output damage, we can...
Oh.
You think they're gonna grab my healings here?
Hello?
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, bye strange.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay.
Guys, guys, we have to, guys, we have to stay on point, guys.
Just literally, oh my god, there you go.
Fuck it, we're gonna fight this.
We have to fight this.
We have to all kill something.
We have to kill something here.
Alright, at least we stabilize, that's all that matters.
Okay, I'll take the stabilization.
Because we only have one fight.
Now we made it so there's one fight left.
Oh, and now we have three tanks.
All right.
Strange, please.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
They don't know why I'm here.
I don't know who's there, too.
Bez?
They don't know why I'm here.
I don't know why I'm here, too.
I'm back.
This is like a magic shot.
I hope my heels are going over.
Like that's all that matters.
I think my heels are.
Yeah my heels are.
Okay my heels are.
Yeah yeah.
They don't know.
What they don't know won't.
Oh shit my only cover from Spider-Man.
Okay this could be like the biggest eat of all time for them.
Okay.
Hello!
Please, we need to kill one guy.
Please!
Okay.
Oh my god, they have Spider-Man.
Oh, it's over.
It's over already.
Guys, it might be over.
We're not killing anything and we use all our alks.
We're not killing...
Oh no.
Guys, please!
We're not killing anything, guys!
my god we did oh no we're even now we're even
that's all i want i just wanted to kill him okay we're even we're plus one this could be the biggest on of all their all time oh and that's me oh my god if they went because it was truly the biggest all of all time yeah thank god lovely playing with you dokey Thank fucking God The dream lives on We take those We fucking take those With minus two on our team I mean they had one support Like if they had double support I think they could have won that They're gonna lie Like legitimately They needed like one more support This guy was a fucking menace society I get him I get JJ out the biggest chef of all time i don't even know who is okay yeah never mind no this guy i know no this guy this guy's playing mystery heroes
yeah jeff with a steel chair he was like you know what maybe it'll work a second time all right back to the real content now i they went double support they could have easily won that they were doing solo they were doing solo jeffy's like they they absolutely tried so hard to not win wait where are the women bucky's kitty does invis have a dancing mode i don't remember
she would like to be um i am recruiting right now for my business i can make you a stop you can make so much oh sue doesn't what's the point what the fuck is the point where are my dancers at it's mantis spider-man we don't even have a oh wait venom venom do you have twerk
It's literally the evil- do you have butt shake emo?
I can't even say twerk, but yet it's in the fucking shop.
What is it even called?
What is it even called in the shop?
I'm pro, but it was for- Oh shit, wait, he does, he does.
Come here, I will make you a star.
Relay deployed
No No It would let me open my My establishment I don't understand My perfectly legal establishment There's no laws against stripping How dare they sabotage my business How dare I know some very powerful people in the government
If anyone in Marvel could be a pimp, it'd be Rocket.
Yeah, there's no laws against stripping.
Only prostitution.
But only to get cut.
Capitalism is not a crime.
Exactly.
I'm surprised Loki doesn't have a dance emote.
That's what the curtains are for.
Can't get caught if there's a curtain there.
It's only illegal if you paid.
Let my people strip.
Wait, where is he?
Wait.
Oh my god, my usual...
Okay.
Big venom.
Do you have booty shake emo?
Things are gonna be different this time.
Loki should have a dance emote.
I don't understand.
Why everyone's so violent in the morning?
How dare you?
Oh wait, Star... Yeah, but I don't think... No, this Starlord's a bitch.
He's not an role player.
He ain't no RP here.
Now dance.
That's right.
Open for a bit.
No!
That's right.
He only did one shake and that's it.
I pay very well.
I'll let you know.
Why does no one want to go to the club?
I don't understand.
Does no one want to support your local businesses anymore?
What happened to supporting small businesses?
What happened?
I don't understand.
You know, um, the customers pay, and that's all that matters.
They get paid, and it's like working at fast food, where, like, majority of your pay comes from tips.
I like that.
How else do you think franchises stay that?
How else do you think they stay that big?
You get majority of your pay from tips.
look at that you get experience and dollar bills what's more than what else is there to ask for hey guys oh in the bedroom oh this is a private show now this is a private show guys i swear to god i've been here for five minutes i still have yet to have a have staff at my business Come on big venom.
Come on.
It's right here.
This is a very expensive pull.
Oh, that's right, girl.
Oh, she gone.
Not even in the honeymoon suite.
You think I made up money?
I can only afford one pull.
Guys.
That's all I have.
I only can afford one pull.
We gotta start small.
I got this.
I got the lease for like $300 a month.
I don't even own this pull.
I rent it.
Alright.
Come on.
It's just this easy.
Look, I'll give you an example.
Look at that.
Whoa.
It's like this.
And now you do it.
Look at that.
Whoa!
that easy.
Now you go, Jeff.
We don't discriminate.
Look at him.
I'm doing tricks on him, too.
Can't believe it.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Doki's business?
That's a crazy first message.
Doki's business is show business.
Now show me that booty shake.
Alright.
oh we have triple support banish from this match
alright we're at 8 banning imagine stream reward clip is just honestly that's the best part of the rivals whoever signed up the new RP meta shout out to you oh wait I even saved it I signed on my feed yes soon I want soon my will be just as big as this guys one day that's my dream chat one day I will own a successful business like these that rocket there one day we all gotta start
small I aspire to reach that level I took a loan from the bank and everything
I believe in you.
Why are they so successful?
How did they get three mantises?
I could barely get one.
I don't understand why they don't want to work with me.
Oh, we have four support players.
Okay, that's not good.
I don't understand.
Lady PS in this elo?
Also, why the fuck are you awake, Gomez?
Oh, wait, it's like...
Never mind, I forgot your East kiss.
Oh, shit, we're in the tier 3?
If this battle is to be won, it will be because you are on our side.
I didn't realize, Gomez, that's a Dragoon right there.
Because I took a nap, technically asleep, at 10 p.m.
Alright We really are gonna run.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oh, I mean we have in this so like Was it really like that scary?
Oh I do see a spot man, so goodbye
Okay, I hope we kill them.
Oh we don't that's why it's just streaming.
I mean we're here to make our dreams a reality Jesus Christ that's five minutes just gonna keep pulling
I'm just scared about this oh there you go goodbye there's so many pullers when we have one Invis
I mean everybody's just pulling like I don't know how to stop him oh he was so low too oh poor Phoenix I did everything thing I could.
Which is not that much, but like I'm just one little guy.
Oh my god.
Maybe we just don't have enough damage.
Just maybe.
We have so many heals.
Like I cannot build it all charge.
I just have to build all from just DPSing, which is bad because I don't play Mantas that much anymore.
Oh shit, Yes!
Or Jeff did it.
You know, I believe.
I have not fucking played Mantis in so long.
Like, I just play her like irregularly whenever I'm forced to play triple.
Because she's the best triple of Sephora character.
Don't worry, I wake you up.
No sleeping time on the job.
I'm not paying overtime.
I mean, I hope we have up where, um...
There we go.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Um, it's a little bad that, uh, because I don't have up yet.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I literally just hit one.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, so we don't have up.
Or the only issue is that we might not have up.
for uh spider-man up so good luck everyone i'm i'm ready oh shit nice wait how do we wait who messed with him who the messed with him who did that oh my god who stopped it oh that's unlucky i cannot see only 60 seconds left that's crazy he got messed up
I don't know who messed with him, but someone did.
Oh.
I'm a little worried, so...
There's a guy right here.
Oh, he's one.
There you go.
That's strange as up, so I'm a little worried, too.
Jesus, they all have up.
There's so many else right now.
We only have Jeff defensive up, too.
Okay, okay.
Bye.
Oh, I need a heal.
Good luck Okay, don't worry, I'm healing There is a guy right here.
Oh, it's unlucky We have invis.
Oh we do Oh, invis please I'm dying.
No, invis No, she held it.
Why?
Why did she hold it invis?
Oh my if she didn't hold it we win she held it the last second too that's so unlucky because i had my own right after we could have fucking rotated else there that's so unlucky the timing she even used it too that's the worst part the fact that she used it too so they don't we only have my i mean i could start it with my Fuck it.
I believe in us.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Okay, we don't need to start with my arm.
There you go.
I think we...
Oh my...
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my god!
Never mind, I don't got you.
I...
Never mind.
Oh my god.
I didn't think we were gonna push that up.
That's so unlucky.
I should have ulted early, too.
I was like, Whoa, everyone!
Whoa, whoa!
Whoa, guys!
Whoa!
This sucks because, like...
This is bad just because, like, the strange has all...
Because I've interrupted it, so it's, like, at 50%.
oh no
nice I don't know who I'm healing that is also an issue I don't really know who I'm healing right now there's so many people in front of me
so fuck get this guy get this fucking raccoon wait wait he's so low I mean he's 1h He's 5 HP, but he's so low.
There you go.
I love here.
Oh!
TP, TP, TP, TP, TP.
Did I?
I don't think I did.
You stunned the stranger, I was hoping.
Where is he though?
I don't think I can.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
All right, the double.
Oh my god, he dodged it.
Okay.
Oh, I don't know how he died to that.
I don't know how he died to it.
Oh, she got ulted.
She got strange ulted.
That's so unlucky.
That's so unlucky for her.
I didn't even realize she got ulted.
That was, I could have, I could have healed her.
I thought she was fine just because she got her alt off.
I didn't realize she fucking ulted so early.
I mean that's smart, she predicted it, but yeah, because of that I didn't realize.
Normally you know, everybody's like reactionary, so the fact that she was able to get that alt off.
Oh, guess I'll go down now, we don't have a tank anymore.
He's so low.
That's unlucky.
We only used a leopard for the last fight.
Where is that?
Oh my god.
He is not having a good time.
He is absolutely.
Bro, I'm trying.
I'm trying, Jeff.
I don't have heals.
How many there are Jeff yet?
He got the mantis.
Don't give them another inch.
Our rocket is not having a good time.
No, our rocket is...
Oh my god, I gave you everything!
We are undefeatable!
I don't have leaves anymore, I'm sorry.
I'm taking every damage possible.
Yeah, that's unlucky.
Oh man, that first point That fucking first point Time to switch things up Including which side you're on Life energy is a powerful weapon Yo Who's he yo-ing for?
Yo
Yo yo I don't think I was the problem I'll just say that.
It ain't me.
I'm never the issue.
If I stream, I'm not the problem.
That's how it goes.
30 seconds before you attack.
Yeah.
It's called a streamer buff.
Oh yeah, these feel free to nominate me for my rival streamer.
I really appreciate it.
It's why I'm doing these fucked up hours stream because these are the only times I can stream rivals outside of my regular schedule.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All right, I just got to follow the widow around.
I don't know if our widow's good, but I'll follow her around.
There's our way to go.
That is all I can do.
There you go.
She's asleep now.
Like, can we wake her up?
What the fuck?
I look away for one second.
I'm gonna say, what the fuck happened?
Oh my god, she actually dodged it.
Can we get that...
Strange?
That's like, literally... Oh, never mind.
Yes, he lives.
Unless...
There's our widow.
There you go.
Just push up with that.
Yay!
Oh my god, there's a Starlord right here.
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's fine.
He's got the healers.
Alright, here's a little damage boost for you.
I don't know if I should, like, let her trust in my Adam res.
Or just use it.
I don't know.
He's like, do I trust...
He's like, do I trust my atom?
Oh, I can't.
I'm gonna put that off.
Alright, fuck it.
Let's go.
Ooh, that's not yet.
He does have res though.
I know for sure.
We do too.
Oh, he should, we should raise, we should raise this.
Alright, that's smart.
I'm trying to help you.
Nice.
We just don't have anything after that.
What?
Oh my god.
I was in the corner.
You just have more DPSs.
Oh.
I thought I was safe.
you I'm so sad oh yeah I believe in my widow I don't know it's sort of looking less and less winnable right now it's sort of may or may not look less and less winnable as we go on oh cheap time Oh shit, oh my god, if she had like my damage boost and rocket damage boost,
it would have been crazy It would have actually gone crazy Wait, where's the One of you guys can kill him, right?
You can kill one pesky little magic Holy shit, she farmed so much damage off of that
I don't know Oh wait, I'm less oh are widows gaming?
That's all we need Yeah, chase after him chase after him ain't so perfect if you're dead.
Oh fuck.
I'm sorry Strange strange come back here
Exactly can't be a perfect being if he's a he's fucking dead Perfect being doesn't die guys.
That's all I'm saying Oh shit Dennis there you go i feel like i have to save it yeah i'm chilling i'm chilling
all right oh okay that's fine i'm just gonna go for you oh nice we're good
i had to i got scared so i used it i don't know i don't know if that was was a waste.
I was like, what if he killed?
I'm just saying, what if he kills all of us?
Was that one star lord all?
It could happen.
You know, it was possible.
Maybe, I know I could have trusted my team, but it was possible.
I have to go to my widow.
And when I'm coming over, I'm platforming real quick just give me a sec I caught a platform oh my god hey yes there is a strange right here very nice oh nice made him use born again I'm gonna back up slowly cuz I don't know widow you're not with me widow oh look I did warn her destroy this first oh i guess we leave goodbye everyone goodbye do i born again no we do not yeah this widow is actually crazy i'm trying my best to like babysit her but then she went high ground and that's when the babysitting stopped i need assistance unfortunately unfortunately high ground is my limit Like,
I'm not, my legs are not, like, strong enough.
I didn't even realize we did a hook.
I got you, widow.
There you go.
Well, I hope everything is good for us.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Um, our team's dead.
It's just us, dude.
Oh, mommy!
Oh, shit, nice.
I got the res, too.
Let's go.
How the fuck that didn't give me a sneak?
That's crazy.
There you go.
Just run at him.
Again!
You got this, Forky!
Oh, never mind.
He went to steal.
Fucking coward.
Alright.
You got all the damage boost in the world widow.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I have no leaves I only used it for that.
Oh, no There you go.
I can't see shit, too, which is bad.
Where's my widow?
Oh, there she was.
Sorry, buddy.
There she was.
Are you serious?
I can get her here oh we're dead uh no i might i don't watch really watch much tournaments i think the most exciting part of the tournaments is just at the end during the finals i don't know just not a i like playing competitive i'm not like uh i'm not like a oh my god that's all of it gave you everything.
I'm not like a watcher.
I don't like what.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I did turn around.
I.
That's very unlucky.
I don't know if he gets that.
Okay.
Here you go.
Porky.
Go.
Oh.
We have to live this.
Please keep on getting.
Please, kill him!
Oh, no.
Okay, that's fine.
I don't have leaves.
It might not be fine anymore.
Stay on point.
It's okay.
Jesus Christ.
It's literally just the tanks.
There we go.
Okay, this is a little worrisome now.
This is a little bit worrisome now.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Now I just need to do zero assists after that.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
after that.
Buy a threat.
I mean, to be fair, I'm literally just babysitting our widow.
I'm not, like, doing anything else.
I'm just, like, I'm, like, take my leaves.
I'm just, like, take it, you whore.
Take these leaves.
No, I'm not doing so.
You can, like, the Simba 9-0 guy, the other Mantis he's vibing.
You can tell that he does play DPS all I do is pocket I'm supposed to do more kills as mantis but like I don't know I'm just not used to playing here it's been so long I mean if it was like season 0 or 1 then maybe but it's just I don't have a lot of time on her since I started playing the other supports
I don't want to waste nice.
I'm trying to make sure.
I'm trying to make sure she always has two.
But the thing is, I'm also not really...
Nice.
I'm not doing... I'm not building ults right now, which is bad.
Oh, this is...
I think we guys, we...
You might have to, you know, stop the cart.
Guys, we should stop the cart, guys.
Oh, or not.
You know, it's just like, you know, suggestion.
It's just a nice suggestion to have.
There you go.
Again!
there you go wait that's not good hey you guys that's not good all right oh that is not good that is absolutely not good that is please I almost have a we are we gonna push in come on oh my I have to use it.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
I thought we were going to rush in.
They have Starlob portal now, so good luck everyone.
Legendary.
Oh, there we go.
Yay!
Who let Strange die first?
Or last.
body block the current score is three two oh that's thank you for the red thank you thank you yeah you know when i mantis saw i just ran straight in i should have anticipated the strain jump into the mantis um yeah i should have may have should have predicted that it's my bad that was a big my bad
jesus christ stat wise we should win but it's not about stats apparently
guys i don't know stat wise logically we should win but i don't know anymore anything can happen in marvel rivals
i'm just i'm the assist mantis all i do is just all i do is just damage booster i met our widow i follow her around like a fucking die.
They're like, I want damage boost and I'll be like, bow, wow.
Four, three, two, one.
Maybe she can get like a chickpea.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to damage boost.
No more leaves.
We just need that, you know.
One hit.
Oh my god.
I want a heal and I want a damage boost.
It's like, I'm so conflicted.
I'm just trying to give them as much damage boost as possible.
Well, which is two.
I'm trying, guys.
I'm trying to save it all for our widow.
Where did she go?
Careful getting pushed off the map.
oh there you go 10 seconds they're gonna save it for this fight
there you go oh my god no we got chain we got chain we got oh nice please we gotta kill no we had to kill it oh we did it guys we there is like this guy
yay how the Fuck did he build alt so fast?
I was at 68.
Like, bro, that mantis build alt so fucking fast.
My dual king.
Jesus Christ.
That's his name.
He's easy.
Is he streaming?
Yeah, he is.
.
Well, not the widow.
I know forky fucking streams.
But I don't know.
Like, usually...
No snitching.
Someone's really like, no snitches.
We'll never know, I guess.
We'll never know who he is.
That guy is crazy.
He has to be somebody.
An average key.
All right.
What the fuck?
Okay, I was going to say, why is there Luna?
I guess we'll never know.
I was going to be like, what the fuck?
Why is he playing Luna?
If I can play DPS, I'm touching Luna anymore.
Yeah, no, it's obviously an all-out account.
Of course.
all I'm saying is like if I if I can aim like that like goodbye support I'm done with you like no it's someone it's just someone smurfing like not smurfing but just someone um on a on a secret oath account we'll
never know unless he said it in an earlier stream
they avoided all wait I got avoided Like, they're like, no worry, I avoided our whole, what did I do?
What did I, bro, I pocketed you.
I pocketed the shit out of you.
What the fuck?
I followed you around and everything.
What is fuck me for?
After all the leaves I gave you, he said, fuck you too.
I gave him so many leaves.
I don't understand the betrayal.
The actual betrayal.
I pocketed him out.
He's banned from my strip club.
That's it.
I'm blacklisting this man from my strip club.
He ain't getting any from the mantises I have in my club.
Yeah, he took all my leaves and for what?
uh levy uh levy thank you for the 200 biddies thank you thank you yours ever have resonated so well i dealt with same issue i appreciate the stream oh i'm glad it helped out a lot and i glad i'm sad i'm so sad he fucking disposes me as if i'm nothing what's the point where's the integrity anymore i followed him around and everything too i gave him all my oh my god it's time
I scouted him Oh my god I scouted the next I'm gonna make you a star girl I saw how you were dancing And I knew I knew you were gonna be a star Look at you go Wait let me put it closer to you Give me a sec I gotta put it in between you two I saw you had a dancing mode too I
Preventory talent agency.
I found two stars!
I found my...
I found them.
Which hero do you think I fucking found them?
Oh my gosh.
Do I have to play Mantis again?
Do I...
Oh yeah, no.
I've been wanting to play Dispatch.
It's just my schedule is super...
schedule is just super uh packed for this week and like i didn't have time to do like a long playthrough but i wanted i did want it to do like two parts for um two parts for batman i can't play adam because we don't have luna might as well just go to
pick your hero all right i'm not judging this is five energy is a powerful weapon against evil The Dispatch Episode 1 is out now, and it's like five hours.
So, but I didn't have a time to do, like, an actual long, long stream today.
Or not today for this week, so I was just like, oh, I'll just, I'll just, yeah, for next.
Actually, I can't even do next week, because next week it's, like, freaking Street Fighter.
Also, I'm going to, I, it's not announced yet, but I'm, I mean, you'll see in my schedule for next week, But I also have an Apex Legends hide-and-seek tournament on Saturday as well.
So it's like mega fucking packed.
Because it's like Tree Fighter tournament.
And I haven't even practiced that yet.
I'm planning on doing that like either today or tomorrow.
But there's Tree Fighter.
And then there's apparently I'm one of the seekers for the hide-and-seek tournament.
That's hosted by Nokia.
So there's that.
And yeah.
So it's like all over the place.
So I don't have a lot of space to do anything else.
No, no, and there's a sponsor thing I have to do next week as well You'll find out what no don't worry next week.
I'll tell you the story of why I was so fucking stressed out Yesterday and like the day the day before yesterday Oh, hey, what That's the most Hail Mary shit How the fuck did I?
What is he doing there?
I have, I should technically...
Oh, there you go.
Don't worry, the clone's asleep now!
I got you guys!
I got the clone!
Guys, can we kill this one giant tree?
Like, is that a little bit too much to ask for?
Alright, they're running triple as well.
I didn't realize we capped it.
I was just like waiting.
I was like, why is it not capping?
Oh my god, that's so many headshots.
Wait, I'm giving you two leaves after that.
That was a lot.
All I heard was ding ding ding But you get two leaves now.
I swear to god if you avoid me after I give you two leaves, I swear to god
All right, almost have all up too.
Here here's two leaves you whore That's right, I know what you want.
Okay, he's gonna ult, so I'm not gonna do anything.
Jesus.
I'm backing up for that.
I am ready to put on a show.
He poured the ult.
He's so confused.
Look at how fucked the ult, girl.
Oh wait, that's the raccoon.
guys please oh thank god oh shit no I got you oh I thought we were all looking at him but I guess not nice oh Celestia's so easy now it's like everybody ranked up or some shit it's like all the good players aren't in this Elo right now all
I got a gamer move right here.
Watch this.
It's called pressing Q!
Don't worry, I'll wake you up.
That's right!
Look at that!
Look at that, guys.
Isn't that crazy?
He has all.
I'm fucking giving me a sec.
I'm leaving.
Oh my god, I...
What?
Okay, that was, that should have hit.
It literally gave the hit sound marker too.
Which that sucks.
Oh, nice.
He none.
Oh god, she pressed the button.
No, Loki fucking sucks.
Unless you're, I guess like he's okay in triple support, but he's fucking terrible in general.
Nobody has ever pressed Q like that before.
I feel empathy for an enemy and still destroy.
Yeah, I know all the pros are like in it.
Yeah, all the pros aren't playing, so the games are a lot easier.
It's more of a comp point flip, though.
I'd say all the casuals are just playing.
No, he's, like, hard nerfed.
He's not really, like, meta.
And he's only okay in triple support, and even then, there's better characters to play in triple support, like, Adam.
Right over.
Adam over Loki.
He's still pulling my heart.
Yeah, they, like, got a bad nose, like, you're next.
he's okay in triple support but even then like um like you have to have like really good coordination that's why he's terrible in ring you have to have really good coordination for it to work in a in a pro environment which is basically what pro play is but even then like only a couple of teams can utilize it well that's why you don't see a lot of teams use and then triple support because only a few care only a few pro teams can use him okay what you fucking shimmy to the left that's it oh
that's so fucked up
he literally gave him a five man our and the Angela gave him a fucking five man that's one again like you know That's not fair!
Like, are you- are you actually got the assist?
That's so fucked up.
There we go.
Oh, there I go, apparently too.
I swear, please, please!
Get him out of here!
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh no, please, I don't want to get in the noise clip.
Please, please!
This is not fair!
Please!
No, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no noise complaint not again what what no no oh my god this is so bad I'm actually getting noise complete getting call outs this is that was so bad I mean I'm gonna try and use my load first oh my god I could not focus too all right this is it I swear to God I hope he keeps it for I hope our cloak keeps it for yep there it is yep that's what we needed I was like if we don't win this we have to have the cloak up for the Star Lord all yeah there he comes he's coming over he's walking to me menacingly.
Are you serious?
I...
I was trying so hard to avoid him.
That's crazy.
I was doing everything I can to avoid him.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
I need a farm for these.
There you go.
Oh my god, thank god the mags save- Oh!
Thank god the mags save me.
Okay, we still- we're still rotating our support ults.
Gotta make sure our Hella gets all the damage boost he needs.
Goodbye.
He's doing it.
He's putting on a show.
Go do your fucking headshot shit while I back up.
They do have mantis, which I am afraid of.
Alright.
I'm so confused.
Like, what are they looking at?
I'm trying my best to help out.
I'm like, what are you guys looking at?
okay I have a yeah we go in this is it they have no lamps all right now they replicate it where's my fucking hello okay there he is all right he has oh and I'm looking I'm gonna slowly back away I know what you are oh no we don't have supports.
Oh, it's to rotate this, which is pretty bad.
Are you serious?
He was so low, too.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
I am trying my best.
I am... Oh my god, it's too late for us.
It's okay, we have a rocket.
We have...
Oh my god.
Like, yeah, we lived that.
Winning, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I was, like, fucking trying to make sure our hello was alive.
He was, she was, like, carry out of all of that.
I was like, I see her deleting everyone.
I was like, this guy will get all the leaves possible.
He's the only one getting leaves.
Single final Mattis goes fucking crazy.
Look, my goal, I see Loki, I farm Loki heads, and then I give it to our Hella.
Yeah.
That's it.
I'm not here to kill.
That's my Hella's job.
I'm here to farm damage.
Farm damage to get.
Look, this man just had two.
Double me, but, but like, it's all of, it's Hella's.
Today is Hella's Day, not my day.
All right, I'm gonna.
I want to give dad food because I don't want to get a noise complaint.
I'll be right back.
Wait, don't worry, guys.
Don't worry, though.
I'll make sure you get a dinner and show.
I'll be right back.
Clip to Club Doki.
Everyone.
Alright, do a match.
I gotta expand my business.
One day.
One day my business will be just like those other.
Rockets.
One day.
What the fuck?
Hate crime.
What's going on?
What's going on in my premises?
No hate crime allowed.
Everyone's equal in my strip club.
As long.
As long as you know what you want.
Ladies.
Whoa!
Okay.
She's not a... She's blacklist.
Who is harassing me?
Except for that fucking widow player.
Fuck that guy.
I did so much for him.
And he's like, I avoided the whole team.
Fuck you.
All I did was shove leaves in your mouth.
What more do you want from me?
Alright.
The club is open.
Club Doki Bird is back in.
back in action.
Hello, do we have any dancers?
I'm scouting out some talents right now.
Any dance.
Look, here, this is what you have to do.
Here, I'll give you guys an example.
You go up here and you're like, Whoa!
That's all you have to do.
And that's like, yeah, we have an all you can eat wings buffet, too.
That's when you know it's a good club.
It's a...
That's when you know.
Here, I'll give lessons, guys.
Look, look.
Look at this.
That's what you gotta do, ladies.
Is that easy?
Any takers?
Come on, come on.
A business needs only one dancer.
The startup club.
They do not want it.
What kind of RP server?
is this this is amateur hour guys how could you fucking play doom how could you queue up for to roleplay when you don't rp they do not this is the office roleplay follow please not for me for her what's her rank
She saved my life.
Here is the lore.
Okay, this is apparently...
This is the RP session now.
Alright, we're gonna hear somebody's life story.
It was me against a gang called Diablos.
Citywide gang.
I won.
So how the fuck did she...
How did she save your life if you already won?
story time at my strip club
great story love the ending won the battle but lost a war type shit how did you how did he lose she gave me the cookie that's all it takes your expectations are low buddy
If I give you two cookies, would you advertise my channel?
I'm gonna poach his viewers.
Yeah.
Leave her.
There we go.
This is not the roleplay I wanted.
Bye-bye now.
Follow, please.
You can't just ask him to leave it.
What?
He had...
Bro, he had such low expectations, man.
One cookie and...
That's all it takes for him to, like, ride or die for her?
You gotta...
You know, he's gotta, you know, look bigger.
For most guys, yeah.
You know?
What's that word?
He's gotta, like, have higher standards.
It was a really good cookie.
I'm sad.
My strip club is failing.
I don't know what I can do
Hey guys I don't know what to do guys I took a loan and everything like no one wants to dance I don't understand.
Why does no one want to dance?
Oh my god, wait Wait, why do we have a fucking wait, I'm fucking Celestia 3.
Why?
One guy is one above all.
Okay, can I chill now?
I don't want to aim anymore.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
Can I chill now?
Alright, I believe in my team I'm doing bans because I don't know how to... I don't play enough this season to know what the...
Because like last season, it was easy.
It was Torch, Phoenix, Emma, and then the fourth one is a free-for-all you can do whatever fuck you want this season i'm not too sure now i don't know i don't play enough for it to figure this out
now don't don't ban bucky don't ban bucky we have a bucky player fucking noobs target band name wait who was it oh someone target band the spider-man No, Zexo Rival's gonna talk to me.
Oh, they're full of sniping.
That's shameless.
Wow.
Who are they sniping?
Oh, my, wait.
You can go.
I'll go back.
I gotta go Groot Knight with DMR.
Who could it be?
Oh, my God.
I'm going back to my room.
Nobody likes me.
Wait.
streaming right now who the fuck is streaming right now how dare they who could it possibly be I
know right it's the morning it's eight in the morning oh to be fair to be fair they are doing um it is the what's it called it is the ignite soon when is ignite i end stream before ignite starts because i don't really i'm not doing a watch party
i mean i feel like oh my dad angela
How fucking dare they?
Alright, there you go.
Thanking it.
It's too early for a stream, guys.
I'm just keeping my pull up just for, uh, just in case.
Because I can, I can see there's an Angela near us.
There you go.
I'm like, little worried.
about the edge of the pool that's really it I need a pull I need a pull instead of push but like it's just reflex at that point I've done push so many times that I keep like I keep pushing instead I need a pull more like who else first whoa
whoa rocket you can do what first
caught me Look at that You can't say i'm throwing now.
I talked Can't be throwing if I've communicated to my team Oh, I missed my pull Hello guys, I'm dead okay
Okay I you know I expected I don't know.
We were all in the crowd, and it was me.
I'm coming over now.
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
I can't even do anything about that.
I got scared.
I know.
We were all solo.
You don't understand.
We were...
Wait, wait.
All of us was 20.
And we were like, all of us was one.
one hp holy i don't know it was you don't understand we were all critical anything could have happened
anything could have happened guys
i'm giving him like this if he dies i'm scared Like, I'm fucking trying my best to not be on high ground.
What the fuck?
That's our Bucky there.
There we go.
Oh, they went, uh, Squirrel Girl.
I'm cool with that.
That's cool.
That's fine by me.
I think my rocket can heal everybody else.
Oh, wait, we don't have...
Oh, I'm not cool with that, though.
Yeah, I'm not cool with that.
I have to reload, bro.
Okay, goodbye.
Whoa.
It's okay.
I rocked it as hell.
He just needs to throw it out.
Just throw.
No.
Oh, he was getting changed.
We don't have TP!
Wait, what?
Who TP'd?
Who the fuck TP'd?
What happened to her TP?
Who had it?
Who used it?
When did we use TP?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
No one says anything.
We don't know.
Who the fuck used TP?
I'm also just as confused.
Jesus, where the- Where did we have a fucking string?
Someone- Oh, I think someone used TP and then swapped off.
Like, they- they were not expecting.
There we go.
They were like, nah, we don't need it.
Guys, we gotta- We gotta get on point, guys.
Oh.
I hope like they're okay over there.
There we go.
I was gonna say, I hope everything is fine.
Yeah, someone was like JK, which is very unfortunate.
Oh my god.
This is a bit scary.
Oh, he's dead, bro, please!
please i'm trying to fucking use not use my alt right now i'm very scared i'm like trying to use trigger discipline to not use my alt oh goodbye angela did he get him i don't think he got him
all right at least we got the rest jesus christ bro bro what are you oh okay look at that the I got you covered
What?
Oh, I did not think he'd be there I was gonna say help Oh my god, get me out of here
Okay That's fine I am doing my best I'm literally, I'm just left clicking There's nothing else I can do Okay
um um please get him off of me oh walk forward walk forward i get him off of me
i don't know how i live i swear to god i i got solo ulted and everything i i don't know i'm getting i'm getting oh my throat broke i look at that guy he's gonna win
Please!
I've got all I've been doing is just healing!
She's off, she's off.
She's off.
Holy fuck.
Bro, I got solo ults in and I'm still alive.
That's crazy.
Let's not, let's me and you combo all every time.
We'll just kill through everything.
I feel like a horror victim right there.
Avoid Luna jet pump zero belly.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
You'll need a top notch team to...
I felt like I was in a horror film.
Like, what the fuck was happening?
Oh, it was day.
Yeah, they were stream sniping day.
Thank God.
They didn't know.
Oh, wait a night stream is going now.
I mean.
Let me know when the game starts starting.
And I'll call it.
What the fuck?
Are you the person?
What?
Bro, drop his hat.
Do you know what's funny?
I'm GM by bro.
They're having a cop.
Someone's a fucking Like someone's a criminal and you're like hey guys, you know what's funny?
I'm GM Call someone call the cops
Bro, they're having a real conversation here like an actual conversation Yeah, someone who is on the account brisk or something bro what account sharing in my streamer lobby
real guys they do not care they're like we have three streamers here in this lobby anyway by the way who's on your account who's like on your account right now bro
there's actual I don't care.
That's crazy.
The fact that he's like, hey, there's two streamers here.
Why don't you fucking expose yourself?
What is happening?
Um, we have someone that's a cat sharing.
And then also on the enemy team, we have someone that's an actual fucking criminal.
Uh-oh.
We should vote for you.
You should vote for me.
Oh, yay, we won.
Yippee Oh, why do names get revealed?
It's so like people don't target bad.
If you're a streamer, you just pull up your stream anyway.
So you didn't... Jesus, are you somehow... Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah, there's apparently a PDF in game.
thank you thank you uh unit thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you i actually ranked up i guess i terrorized the enemy team not my own team which is crazy that was not how it's supposed to go this was not how it was supposed to go
terrorizing goes both ways
and it's not my usual hours too who would have thought chat playing video games playing queuing marble rivals ring not at three in the morning means i'll climb that's crazy what what a crazy world we live in happy little accident all right is the next is the game starting yet chat
Are the games starting yet?
I just want to know if I keep going or not.
Just changing her hours, boosted her rank.
They're still doing intro.
Okay, I can still kill another game.
Alright, I'll do one more.
If they're still introducing the teams.
Doesn't hurt.
Yeah, please.
Please vote for me.
Nominate me.
I wish the best mobble rival.
streamer it would be um it would be so awesome to be up there it would be such an honor and um you know that's the one category category i would love to be uh nominated for uh we really mean a lot that's it i will be the dancer martial arts sharpens your mind i'm so sad i wanted to be a business woman but no one i don't understand my idea was like,
my idea was so, was so good.
I don't understand.
There was no cons.
I find I'm doing it myself.
Like, I don't understand.
It's foolproof.
Like, why doesn't anyone want to invest in my strip club?
I don't understand.
Hello, everyone.
This was like, I'll give them I'll give everyone a little, be like, whoa!
And be like, if you want more, you can come to Club Dokey Brewer.
If you like what you see, then come over to Club Dokey Brewer.
We have more for everyone.
Yeah, taste of the champagne room, exactly.
Just like what you see, then come over to Club Dokey Brewer.
keeper and we have ladies and men and maybe even sharks for everyone a dancer a dance oh oh my god there's peter okay wait give me a sec guys i think i got my first dancer i i guys i need to figure out how to all right here you go a little something for every customer exactly okay how do i how do i jump off god damn it where where's the fucking uh Okay,
there's a private room.
Alright, here you go.
There you go.
We got Spider-Man.
My first...
My first worker.
My first staff.
We got a Spider-Man.
But where is he?
Spider-Man!
That's right.
Yeah!
Let's go!
I can't believe it.
We're doing it.
We're becoming successful business owners.
Support your small businesses.
He knows this assignment.
Support your small local businesses right now.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, me.
Girls.
And we have Spider-Man!
Yep.
It's printing, but he's a probe.
He's a professional.
Baby, I'm making you a star tonight.
Spider-Man.
All those amateur photos you're taking?
That's...
That's peasant stuff.
I'm taking you to Hollywood.
You don't have to take those photos anymore for your only fans, girl.
One of those...
on your iPhone.
You don't have to take those photos on your iPhone.
I got something better for you.
He's done this before.
I don't trust me, Spider-Man.
Of course, regarding the split, there'll be a 80-20.
Obviously, I get the 80 because I scouted you.
I discovered you.
If it weren't for me, you would have been nothing.
You'd still be in that bedroom of yours, to JJ.
That's right.
Now those voters are gonna go everywhere, girl.
Now...
You can even keep the tips.
No, the toxic gaslight.
Oh, do we get the same team from last game?
What you think you wanna be today?
I don't even know.
Uh...
Sure.
Let's just play Bakun.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
I think it's, yeah, I think this might be LG, depending on, uh, this might be LG.
Doki tempting Spider-Man, like the green goblin in the first movie.
If I could bring a couch out for Peter, I would.
I'm Forky's widow.
I know you thought I avoided you, but you were the only...
Yay!
Wait, I was!
Val, you're not banned from the strip club.
I'll let you back in.
I'll let you even pick the ladies you want.
Yay!
Not avoided.
Let's go.
Let's go, guys.
I didn't get avoided.
See?
I knew I didn't fuck up.
Pick your hero.
Yippee.
All right, you're off the blacklist, buddy.
See, pocketing the curious...
I mean, if you have a widow, you could just fucking follow them around like a dog.
Like, that's really your only job as Mantis.
I told you it's never me.
I told you.
Can't beat me, I'm streaming.
Streamers never fuck up.
We don't talk about the Stewie 2K situation right now, but streamers never fuck up.
Well, that's crazy, though.
I guess that's crazy.
This guy has won a million plus dollars in just prizes.
as money in general like in just like fucking competing like no that's like the winning the lottery in eSports the and in NA too the only fucking pro play like you can if it's just Asia it makes more sense because like you know um in Asia people get played so much for eSports but like in NA it's so fucking rare to have like um have that much earnings in NA
of that away oh my god they have daredevil this is not okay this is not okay yeah because one of my friends they're like oh man i wish i was a league pro play like pro instead of like um shooter and then i was like bro you're na you ain't gonna get paid i'm sorry it's just the reality though like bro okay i we're trying our best unless you're gonna appeal for us you're not getting healed like me and the cloak has been fuck this yeah i was like bro you're coping if you think you're gonna get paid like that much in any jesus christ oh my god it's still going it's still going
oh my god we just cast that's crazy yeah and i was like look and i was like look up league earnings right now and scroll until you find an na person that has it's like no see look like he this guy in league the number one guy earned like a million yeah who was he and he's like faker i was like exactly are you faker i and then he like scrolled until like you know who it was sneaky that was the highest earned like na person for league and even then it was like like it was so long ago and he was like top like number 30 or some shit it was like number 30 like bro you're You're not gonna be sneaky,
bro.
Yeah, their devil literally was terrorizing me for five minutes straight.
Guys, I don't think we winning this.
Like, you know what we need?
One singular Bucky can change everything, but I guess not.
Oh, yeah, goodbye.
I get it.
You gotta believe.
I don't think we win this, guys.
Guys, this ain't looking so good.
I think we're like, the booty munchers gonna win.
Yeah, but it's actually...
It's actually crazy that...
I mean, gambling addiction is like no joke in general.
Like, it is really sad that...
That that's the thing.
But it's crazy, though.
Like a million dollars.
Yes, gamble that away.
More than a million.
Goodbye.
There we go.
Believe in my teammates.
I believe.
The fact that the cloak and I lived that long.
After what we went through.
We went through so much.
he was like and like he sold skins that belong to other people too which is crazy i think that's fucked up whoa you know my only platform where else can i go on high ground
oh there's a daredevil whoa there i go no whoa oh my god oh my god get me out of here get me out
It's time I wanted to be eaten.
That's so unlucky.
I was one second too late to get to eat.
Oh my god.
I was literally one second away.
That's unlucky.
Alright, I do have a...
He might just destroy it.
But like, you know.
It's a nice cosmetic.
It looks cool.
for five seconds.
And that's all that matters.
You know?
There we go.
Oh, my god.
Goodbye.
Yeah, I ain't getting eaten tonight.
Not tonight.
Not tonight!
Oh, shit.
I got you I got you Oh, they got my res But that's okay, we didn't need it, I guess We didn't need it Oh, they TPed Oh, they TPed Oh, well Here you go Oh Oh, whoa Okay, I may or may not be bringing them closer to us, but that's okay
I'm doing everything I can he has all so like that's what I'm oh there you go I mean I'm fucking I'm shooting Well, like what else can I do?
I'm shooting it.
Oh God.
Oh God
It's okay.
I'm still shooting Like, that's all I can do.
Yay, C9!
Let's go.
Oh, bye.
Thank you for the 10 videos.
Thank you.
That was crazy.
I'm surprised we won that.
That was...
They're going, like, fucking hard-ass time.
I'm surprised we lived long enough for that.
The game started?
Yeah, that's why I'm saying this is LG.
I won't be like, hey, can you guys, like, Game started, guys.
Do you guys want to watch it?
If we win, we can end it early.
So we can all watch Friday the 8th night matches.
Playoffs at Atlanta DreamHack, guys.
Isn't that cool?
You're missing out, everyone.
Come on.
Do you guys want to end the game now?
If you just let us win?
No, I'm not going to watch it, though.
I don't care.
That much for a watch-along.
Also, I have to prep my Halloween stream, too.
Mostly, like, I don't care.
I'm just not a watch-along person, you know?
It's just really that.
Like, it's all preferences, and I'm not...
I don't do watch-alongs in general.
Unless I get paid.
If I get paid, I'll do a watch-along.
But, unfortunately, that ain't happening.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I did not expect that...
I mean, I use...
I mean, we live?
It's not all I meant.
Hello.
Like, he's alive.
I'm just gonna do this.
I think, like, they're fine.
They don't need me.
That's crazy.
They, like, dove our...
Our Hawkeye for 20 years.
And nothing happened.
Okay, so there is a Angela here.
This is why we go Animal Crossing.
I don't know why they're not going Animal Crossing because, like, it would help a lot.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff!
Please.
I help you and you help me.
That's all we need.
Oh, we should!
Bro, there's nothing we can do for you.
you bro there's nothing we can do
oh my god no i know like some co-streamers they get paid for it uh i ain't watching for free time is money i play for free though that's different i will play for free but i ain't watching for free
That's different.
Yeah, it is different because I'm an active participant.
It is different.
I'm an active participant in this lobby.
That was that long.
Jesus Christ, are Jeff built another odd?
What the fuck was he doing?
Oh my god, no more dive.
Thank god.
wanted oh my god okay okay um i mean okay i i don't know what this plan was but okay wait how is there people here
yum yummy yummy yay wait i think we didn't lose any games today
no I plan I want to you are shit I was very surprised we won that game because like the that first fight of me and the other support just fucking fighting for our lives for five minutes straight that was crazy I I was not expecting that That was not, because I don't know how long we lived,
too.
No, no, I am eloterizing the enemy team.
Decent.
Who would have thought when people are actually awake in the East Coast, I, like, actually win games.
Whoa!
All right, we're going to call it here.
Games have started.
Thank you all for watching.
Maybe I'll do another stream tonight.
I'm not sure yet, though.
Who knows?
But thank you all for hanging out with me today.
I have fun time doing this little grind session.
please feel free it would mean a lot to nominate me for marvel best marvel rival streamer i would love to have nomination i don't know if i win i don't think i'm gonna win but i just want to be nominated you know i just want to see my face up there with all these other fleshies i want to represent the vtubers here in this category um anyway guys uh thank y'all for coming i do have the halloween stream later today um that is scheduled on youtube so please uh feel free to check me out on youtube because that's where my main platform is um for those who are new here my name is dokeybird i should stream on that on youtube so every time i do do on twitch it is sort of like a gorilla stream or maybe for sponsors or something so please follow me on twitter where i usually announce whenever i stream on twitch um what else oh yes i do have a controller collab controller um merch now so um if we do exclamation point collab um i have my very own controller merch uh so like my very own controller
and you know uh really will help a lot um if you guys check it out or grab one for yourself it's a really cool vtuber merch too like you don't see a lot of vtubers with their very own controller um but yeah and it's by one of the best um japanese uh controller brands out there so check it out anyway what else what else do i have to show buy my merch i have other merch too i released recently released the halloween voice yay uh so do exclamation point merch and you can check out my other merch on the store um i think that's everything i gotta show anyway guys i'll go i guess i'll raid moxie because he's doing co-streaming for um he's doing co-streaming for ignite so you guys do want to watch the watch the actual official tournament uh and i think i'm pretty sure he i don't know if he gets paid for it but like he loves rivals so i'll give him a rate um but anyway as always everybody stay hydrated posture checked get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up me head
to bed because you deserve it look at that guys didn't lose a single game today look at that i felt like i wasn't the crazy part was that like i was fucking around i was literally having a i was literally talking about league for the first five minutes of that game and we somehow won that's crazy yeah i don't know how we lived yeah we were getting fucking me and the other support by five different people and we still live through it uh and then the other and then the friend that was like please can we get heels and i'm like please we're getting fucking we're getting terrorized right now in the backlight like anyway i'll see you guys next time everyone bye bye guys